昨天看到一則新聞，我整個腦袋都被震驚了，忍不住想跟你分享。
喔？聽起來很特別，是什麼讓你這麼驚訝？
是關於機器人訓練的。我們不是常常聽說AI模型需要大量數據來訓練嗎？
對，沒錯，而且通常都是由專業團隊來執行。
你可能沒想到，現在連這麼複雜的「類人機器人」，居然是靠像Uber Eats外送員一樣的零工，在客廳裡用手機「教」出來的！
哇，這確實出乎意料！訓練類人機器人，我會想像是在實驗室裡，有工程師操作複雜的設備。
對啊！這跟我們傳統對機器人訓練的認知完全不同。一般公司或研究機構，通常會投入巨額資金建立實驗室，聘請專業人員來做這件事。
的確，這種做法感覺成本高昂，而且過程很專業。讓普通人在家裡，用手機，聽起來像是在拍科幻片。
故事的主角之一是奈及利亞的一個醫學生，叫Zeus。他下班回家，打開補光燈，把iPhone綁在額頭上，然後就開始錄影。
錄影？錄什麼？
他會模仿機器人需要執行的動作，像是舉手、把東西放進盒子裡。他錄下自己的動作，然後上傳。
等等，所以是透過錄製人類的動作，來教機器人怎麼動？這有點像我們學習模仿一樣。
沒錯！而且這不是單一個案，而是一個全球性的零工經濟模式。全世界各地，都有像Zeus這樣的人，用手機「教」機器人。
這樣做的關鍵數字是什麼？有多少人參與？
據說有數千人。這些人每天錄製的影片數量非常龐大，而且他們並不需要多高的科技背景。
這確實顛覆了傳統。一般來說，我們會覺得機器人訓練是高度專業化的工作。
這樣做的效率會高很多。透過分散式的工作，可以快速收集到海量的、多元的行為數據。
而且這些數據來自不同國家、不同文化的人，這是不是也代表機器人學習到的行為模式會更豐富，更貼近真實世界？
這是一個非常重要的點。傳統實驗室的訓練，很難模擬到這麼多樣的生活情境和人類行為。
如果我是個創業者或公司主管，我覺得可以從這個案例學到的是，當我們面對一個複雜的問題時，不一定要循規蹈矩。
確實，打破既有框架，去思考「有沒有可能用更輕、更快、更廣的方式來解決問題」。
可以思考把「專業」工作拆解成更小的單元，然後釋放到更大的群體中，讓更多人能夠參與。
這能大大降低成本，而且加速迭代。或許我們可以問自己，我們公司是不是也有某些高成本、低效率的環節，可以這樣「零工化」？
就像這個案例，他們把原本需要機器人專家來程式設計的複雜動作，變成普通人透過模仿來「示範」。
這讓我想到，有些需要大量人力的資料標註工作，其實也運用了類似的模式。
那一般上班族呢？我們可以從中學到什麼？
我覺得是「視角轉換」。當我們遇到看似複雜的問題時，可以嘗試換個角度，思考有沒有「非專業」但有效的方式。
也就是說，不一定所有問題都得用「專業工具」或「專業人士」才能解決，有時候，生活中的智慧反而是關鍵。
對，像這群零工，他們用的就是最簡單的智慧手機，但卻能訓練出科幻電影裡的機器人。
說不定我們工作上的某些難題，其實可以用一些生活化的、直覺的方式來解決，只是我們還沒想到。
很有啟發性。這個案例告訴我們，創新往往不是在最複雜的地方，而是在你可能沒注意到的「普通」角落。
對！所以下次遇到困難，別急著找最昂貴的解決方案，也許便宜又大碗的答案就在你身邊。
這種顛覆性思考模式，確實是值得我們學習的地方。